Alice backto back victories for you
you're definitely back into this
tournament as well your reaction and how
happy are you right
now uh yeah I'm pretty happy because
like um I mean just the way that started
it was uh great for me to just not
continue the losing streak especially
for uh the round four game and I think
this game um it was kind of nice for me
because it was like I don't have too
much risk of losing um but yeah I'm very
happy that I was able to win it was
indeed a very clean game from the
beginning to the end but when did you
feel like you're finally putting the
final finishing touches on this
one yeah I mean to be honest I wasn't so
uh I mean I knew like throughout the
game that I had like a really
comfortable position um especially since
like she went into the end game um I
thought like only I could win I probably
like two res um and I think yeah I mean
once she played D2 I was like really
happy because I knew like um I got into
the opposite color Bishops on it up two
pawns but then I somehow missed like
this bishop A3 move and I knew like I
still had to be winning I was still like
still much easier to play for me but um
yeah like after Bishop A3 and then um
because it was kind of annoying uh I
played like I probably could have just
play Rook C1 immediately instead of keny
2 and that would have just been like a
super easy win um I mean yeah I mean I
was worried that she could like take
with a bishop on F4 but even so that
just still be a um very easy win right
uh and then because now your a pawn
actually runs down the board yeah yeah I
mean uh actually the cwn though I was
kind of glad in the end game that it was
there because you know it kind of
blocked The Bishop's uh diagonal um and
you finally exchang the Rooks at this
point you made the right decision to
exchange the Rooks you had to be uh very
precise in your calculation because
obviously color Bishops we know they
have a tendency to be a draw
but he calculated everything and at this
point after A5 King d8 and this last
moves came not E5 not F5 excuse me but
E5 Bishop to E3 and A6 that's how you
finish the game this must have felt good
those last couple of moves just seeing
these pawns running on a bashed and her
being unable to stop
them yeah yeah I was actually hoping for
Bishop E3 because if she did Bishop F2
then A6 probably wouldn't be very good
she'd have like Bishop H4 but then when
the bishop got D3 was a very nice like
promotion yeah I mean okay here I'm
still winning I take the pawn but um
it's nice when I you still have some
work to
do yeah yes Alice congratulations
important victory for you what did you
do during the rest day to get back into
this
competition um I mean I didn't do that
much I uh in the morning I did some
school work uh and then the afternoon I
was like spend a few hours um like uh
teaching at uh the high school for
Community Day um and that was really fun
uh after that then I started doing
preparation so it's like not too much
different than like a normal day because
uh the teaching kind of is like a few
hours kind of similar to the lens of a
chess game um but it's definitely good
because I was able to get more rested um
and get more sleep Alex good job we'll
see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
indeed Alice as this what